I mean I was a Democrat uh I grew up I  mean I grew up I mean I grew up below  the bottom wrong of the economic ladder  I grew up on a pig farm in Southern  Alabama I grew up in a home with uh no  running water uh no insulation and  Outhouse in the back and a well on the  side when I say poor we couldn't afford  the other oh we were just po but no one  ever told me I was a victim right we  didn't have much but I saw my  grandparents wake up early go to bed  late taking care of their family taking  care of their Community right and no one  ever told me I was a victim and so I  went on to get an education I went on to  get married to have to wait till I got  married before I started having children  so you can learn these particular things  so before we start saying oh it's the  white man's fault or oh it's that black  man's fault or oh it's these people  fault I always want to get the mirror  and put it up in my own face and say  what can I do with my life